I don't know if you heard about this
there's a new anti Obama bumper sticker
that's out there and a lot of people
find this anti Obama bumper sticker to
be very racist and here to discuss this
new controversy is one of our writers
mr. Deon Cole give it up for Deon
Thank You Conan Wow I couldn't believe
this bump is sticking neither but uh
here it is it says don't renig in 2012
don't renege really all I have to say is
that was clever as hell I mean I hate it
is racist but that was clever for real
how they took the word renege and the
n-word and mixed it up so it can have a
racist and political meaning yeah
somebody put some thought into that one
right there that even sound like
something would tank plan to say go
renege on Monday though we'll split two
we are you know
but let me talk to the genius who made
this bumper sticker if you're saying
don't renege in 2012 you're basically
saying vote for Obama again because if
you renege you're taken away but if you
don't renege then you're keeping it the
same right so thank you for your
endorsements you dumb asses
[Applause]